the Last of Us part 2 is officially out
and with it are lots of Easter eggs
callbacks and references be warned this
video contains massive spoilers for the
Last of Us part 2 The Last of Us and the
Last of Us left behind so without
further ado here's 47 things you might
have missed in the Last of Us part 2
let's begin in Ellie's room at the
beginning of the game as there are lots
of hidden little details the first thing
you'll notice is that she's listening to
a Walkman the same one that she's had
since American Dreams the prequel comic
to the Last of Us left behind it makes
an appearance again and left behind and
it's one of the collectibles in Ellie's
backpack in the first game you'll also
notice the savage starlight poster in a
room but not just any savage starlight
poster specifically one of the ones
featured in the first game savage
starlight was also a series of comic
books you could find as collectibles in
the first game Ellie also has posters of
astronauts in her room Ellie is a big
fan of space and this is especially
evident in the sequel more specifically
in the first game when Joel and Ellie
were riding through the university of
eastern Colorado Ellie mentions that if
she had a career she would have wanted
to be an astronaut
that effect yeah you imagine being up
there all by yourself
they call on the shelf next to Ellie's
desk you can see a toy robot this is
actually the same toy that Sam attempted
to take from the toy store in Pittsburgh
Henry made him leave it behind and Ellie
ended up taking it for him there's an
optional conversation in the first game
when Joel and Ellie are headed to
Tommy's when Ellie mentions that she
forgot to put the toy on Sam's grave
meaning she took it back after Sam
turned and still had it all this time
what should I do with it
before Joel plays guitar for Ellie you
can see that he's still wearing the same
watch that Sarah gave him at the
beginning of the first game bullet hole
and all Joel mentions to Ellie that when
he and Tommy went out riding tommy told
him a joke that he thought Ellie would
like this joke is in fact a pun and as
we know from the original and left
behind Ellie is a big fan of puns you
can even earn a gold trophy in the first
game for listening to every pun from
Ellie's pun book when Joel starts
playing guitar for Ellie he actually
starts singing a real song future days
by Pearl Jam the song that was
officially released on October 11th 2013
outbreak day was September 26 2013
so those dates don't exactly add up
according to Pearl Jam's official
website the song was performed live in
July 2013 so there's certainly a chance
Joel heard it and mastered it in record
time or as it was close to release the
finished CDs could have been distributed
post outbreak the more interesting part
about this moment is that in the first
game after Ellie said she wanted to be
an astronaut
Joel admits that when he was younger he
wanted to be a singer Ellie asked for a
sample but Joel doesn't give it to her
where when I was a kid I used to want to
be a singer it was serious I don't think
so
so looks like she finally got her wish
after the performance Joel tells Ellie
that he did promise to teach her guitar
and in the first game we actually see
this dialogue exchange when Joel and
Ellie first enter Salt Lake City yeah
once we're done with this whole thing
and it takes you have played guitar era
I reckon you really like that on top of
all these things that whole scene was
actually adapted from the epilogue
titled The Last of Us one night live a
stage performance version of the Last of
Us that was held one night in San Diego
in July 2014 the biggest difference
between these two versions is that in
the play tommy has hooked Joel up with a
girl named Esther and she's the one who
tells Joel the pun instead of Tommy the
entire one night live show is available
right now to watch on Playstations
YouTube channel except this epilogue
which was only shown to the audience and
was never officially released I wonder
if they always intended for that to be
in part 2 fast forward four years and
now Ellie's a little older and you can
walk around her room on Ellie's dresser
you can see an original ps3 model with
the jak and daxter collection and
uncharted drake's fortune skipping
forward a bit at Eugene's place in the
library he has a ps3 as well except he
has both uncharted 1 and Uncharted 2 now
in the town of Jackson The Last of Us
one enthused composer Gustavo Santhal
aya can be seen playing banjo in the
Jackson crossroads don't remember him
here's a refresher
[Music]
the theater marquee in town reads
September 26 and as we know September
26th is outbreak day meaning that was
probably the last day that that theater
was ever open nice touch
the poster on the theater wall is the
movie titled housebreaking Rufus which
has a release date of fall 2013 again
probably one of the last movies shown
before outbreak a little later in the
game during Seattle day two when you're
playing is Abby and looking for medical
supplies for yara you can actually go
into the animation studio where
housebreaking Rufus was made once Ellie
and Dena head out onto patrol she asks
you to take binoculars to look at the
next town one of the things you can spot
is a strip mall with a Western pharmacy
the Westons chain was also seen and left
behind when Ellie was looking for
medical supplies in the Colorado
Mountain Plaza Mall fun fact
Westen's had an official Twitter account
and their last tweet was sent on a very
specific day once in the library where
Eugene is staying you can find a firefly
pendant and a photo of him and Tommy
together when they were younger from
what we know in the first game Tommy
went off to join the fireflies for a
while before his life in Jackson and it
turns out Eugene served with him during
that time when you enter the children's
section of the library you can find a
stuffed giraffe which prompts Ellie to
draw giraffes in her journal recalling
the iconic scene from the first game one
of the tapes Eugene has is named dong of
the wolf which is a porn parody of Donna
the wolf one of the movie posters that's
displayed all over the first/last of us
another one of the tapes Eugene has is
named smash Brandis couch which sounds a
lot like crash bandicoot inside Joel's
house the photo he has framed of him and
Sarah is most likely the one Ellie stole
from Maria when they first went to
Jackson in part one here Maria showed
this to me and I stole it I hope you
don't mind
once Elly and Deena start heading to
Seattle Elly recounts three specific
events from the first game when Elly
shoots a guy in the face to stop him
from drowning Joel in the Pittsburgh
hotel when they encounter David and his
men aka the cannibals and the black
market smugglers in Boston which is most
likely Robert and his crew from the
beginning of part 1 once Ellie and Deena
arrive in Seattle there are a ton of
gate codes that are needed to advance
the gate code for West to is zero four
five one this code has been a
long-running reference beginning in
Looking Glass Studios games like Deus Ex
System Shock thief etc many games have
referenced it since inside the bank in
downtown Seattle there's a giant vault
you can open inside one of the safety
deposit boxes is a ring that has the
engraving SiC parvis Magna this is Sir
Francis Drake's ring from the Uncharted
series which translates to greatness
from small beginnings there's a trophy
for getting this titled so great and
small which is a fitting name as it's
the literal Latin translation of SiC
parvis Magna also in the bank le Andina
discussed the movie with the surfer bank
robbers aka Point Break I think these
body armor guys were trying to rob the
bank oh [ __ ] it's like that movie which
one the one with the surfer bank robbers
oh yeah I love that movie after leaving
the bank
Elias Tina what she would buy in the old
world with all that money and she says a
farmhouse and Ellie says you can get a
farmhouse now well guess who got a
farmhouse by the end also in downtown
Seattle one of the trading cards you
find is for dr. Oakman who's affiliated
with the new dogs this is a reference to
Neil druckmann director of the last of a
series who's also the VP of Naughty Dog
and has worked on numerous other naughty
dog titles inside the valiant music shop
another location in downtown Seattle you
can find a poster on the wall for Pearl
Jam's 2013 album lightning bolt where
future days is from also in the valiant
music shop when Ellie plays guitar for
Dena she plays take on me by aha except
a much more somber rendition and
unfortunately she doesn't turn into a
moving drawing this is a relatively
minor one but when you enter the coffee
shop in downtown Seattle Deana says
all about coffee inside the hotel in
Pittsburgh in the first game Joel can
find a coffee machine and through an
optional conversation prompt he
reminisces about how much he really
misses coffee Ellie responds Deena by
saying kidding me
he'd trade him half his stuff for a bag
of beans toward the end of the game and
one of the flashbacks Ellie does find
him drinking a cup of coffee and when
she questions him on how he got it he
admits he's a little embarrassed as to
what he had to trade for it dude really
loves his coffee inside one of the
Federer tents in downtown Seattle you
can find a device that tests if people
are infected and Ellie says I haven't
seen one of these in a while referring
to the moment in the first game when the
device was used on Ellie by soldiers who
she Joel and test murder that moment is
also how Joel and tests found out Ellie
was infected but immune when Ellie and
Dina are making their way to the TV
station they go into a store called
Nancy souvenirs which has a ton of
Halloween decorations after Dina
comments on it Ellie says she's not a
fan anything in here just Halloween
stuff some of this stuff is
funny-looking
I'm not a fan this is most likely
because it reminds her of her last day
with Riley and left behind where they
spent some time in a Halloween store
later when Ellie and Dena stumble upon a
bunch of trip wires in Seattle Ellie
recounts the time she and Joel met a
really paranoid man who set up traps
around an entire town
this is referencing bill from the first
game I met this guy once from the Joel's
trip wire to whole town how do people
get around it was just him wait he lived
alone in an entire town he had trust
issues that's sad
kept him alive it's not like you have to
choose between being alive and being
close to people it's not black and white
we take a risk though right you take a
bigger risk being alone like what if he
got hurt what if he got sick what
happens if someone else gets hurt or
sick and you have this added you know
the burden that puts you in a worse
position yeah I guess that's not such a
well let me tell you a story once upon a
time I had somebody that I cared about
partner somebody I had to look after and
in this world that sort of shit's good
for one thing get you killed so you know
what I did why isn't the [ __ ] up and I
realized it's got to be just me once
Ellie and Dena make it to the theater
one of the artifacts Ellie can find is a
poster promoting the sick habit playing
at said theater on September 14th this
is the band whose records Dena remarks
on and the valiant music shop which
Ellie says they've listened to like a
hundred times together they got a bunch
of Records here this leaked habit the
sick habit
no okay we only listen to it like a
hundred times together it's only
listening to it cuz I thought you were
cute Ellie also has a sick habit poster
in her studio in the farmhouse later in
the game the poster has the band's
setlist on the back which suggests that
the equipment in the theater is the sick
habits and mycket our Ellie plays in the
theater quite possibly belonged to one
of her favorite bands during the
flashback where Ellie and Joel are
headed to the Wyoming Museum she asked
him if he got her a dinosaur which he
kind of did dinosaur stop trying to
guess I ain't tell him I'm left behind
when Elian riley first enter the mall
Ellie also asked if the surprise Riley
has is a dinosaur I have a surprise for
you what dinosaur dinosaur he'll just
have to wait and see when walking around
the museum Joel keeps referencing a
movie he saw about dinosaurs which is
certainly Jurassic Park pretty sure
these are velociraptors yeah I mean at
least that's what they called him in his
movie I saw Velociraptor jewel this is
the one you were talking about the
Velociraptor so small yeah don't touch
the movies I guess Compsognathus oh it's
a big name for little guys yeah they'd
swarm you
did you see that in a movie too actually
yeah but a different one see there's a
sequel wasn't as good Brachiosaurus
ate 600 pounds of plants each day Oh
imagine the poops it is one scene where
actually one of the guys said that's a
big mound of [ __ ] what is this movie and
when can we see it tell you what when we
get back to Jackson movie night one of
the dinosaurs you can inspect in the
Wyoming Museum looks kind of like the
giraffe and the shot is framed to very
similarly to how it was when Joel and
Ellie first encountered giraffes in the
first game looks like a giraffe later on
in the flashback Ellie can find a
shipping pallet like the one Joel
carried Ellie on in the first game
because she couldn't swim back then in
another flashback when Joel and Ellie go
to find some new guitar strings you can
find savage starlight number six titled
accretion lying in the cabin where Joel
and Tommy do their patrols
you remember those savage starlight
comic books a year into yeah Tommy and I
found some when we were moving through
at school the other day did you like
them
oh you know what it's not really my cup
of tea even dr. daniela star amines she
pretty
she's a savage well when she does the
captain Ryan and that death match yeah I
mean he definitely deserved it but
there's a nice twist how they escaped oh
you're funny later when Ellie is on her
way to the aquarium she stops in an
abandoned arcade and in the arcade you
can find the cabinet the turning the
turning was featured and left behind
when Riley helped Ellie imagine what it
was like to play it since the machine
was busted it also makes an appearance
in Bill's town in the first game where
Ellie says she has a friend who knew
everything about the game referencing
Riley would you play this before no but
I had a
that knew everything about this game
apparently there's this character called
angel knives who'd was it she punch a
hole through your stomach before kicking
your head off I'm never a big fan of
these things I wish I could play it
there are also a ton of arcade machines
that are in both part two and left
behind including Jack X racing iron
shell
tetsu masu tournament fighter instinct X
triple Phoenix baboon wrench Geoffrey
gobble Boy Patriot wings urban rush and
metal racing fast forward to Abby and
when Manny initially wakes her up during
her day one we see that she fell asleep
reading a book titled city of thieves by
David Benioff the main character of the
book is named Lev the same name is one
of the seraphic kids uber friend later
on on top of that Bruce Straley
co-director of the original last of us
said the novel was a major artistic
inspiration for the game there's even a
newspaper article you can find at the
university of eastern colorado in the
first game written by one levee any off
on their way back to base after being
ambushed Manny talks about finding a
couch watching movies and drinking until
he passes out once they get back oh yeah
let's drink which movie strong questions
movies the one with
I'm a girl who rides the wall oh this is
a reference to the studio ghibli film
Princess Mononoke especially since Manny
mentioned earlier that he's a fan of
anime this is so much better than
getting drunk and watching anime once
they return to base
Abbey can talk to a fellow soldier about
whether she finished the book The Count
of Monte Cristo this is Alexander Dumas
is famous tale about a protagonist who
works and waits for years to exact
revenge
maybe Abby took some pointers one of the
wolves Abby can interact with is named
Whitney who she can find at the base
playing hotline Miami on a PlayStation
Vita yes this is the same Whitney that
Ellie encounters when she goes to find
Nora there's also a mother wolf playing
Evita and his name is Jordan he's the
guy who ties up Ellie only to get
stabbed in the throat and the mess hall
Jordan is playing the fire canyon
section of jak and daxter the precursor
legacy from the jak and daxter
collection which did in fact come to
Vita in June 2013 when Abby sets out to
find Owen she ends up in Chinatown and
in the upper level of the store King
Street relics she finds a precursor orb
from the jak and Daxter series this is
also how you unlock the trophy relic of
the sages another store she can go to on
our quest to find Owen is a comic book
store and inside the store is a bunch of
merchandise for a series called galactic
war which is a homage to Warhammer 40k
with similar icons from the franchise as
well as giant spaceship Marines much
later in the game when Ellie and Dena
are living in the farmhouse you can find
a few more savage starlight comics from
the first game including comic number 13
title catalysis and comic number 2
titled messenger particle also worth
noting that a lot of stuff from Ellie
and Joel's houses have been relocated
here the song Ellie plays on the record
player in the farmhouse is ain't no
grave written by Johnny Cash this cover
is by crooked still unlike the Pearl Jam
song from earlier this was recorded in
2009 so the timeline here checks out
there are actually a few songs by
crooked still in this game including the
song little Sadie which plays during the
party scene he saw during e3 2018 there
are a few other real songs scattered
throughout the game - like ice cubes it
was a good day when you first find Nora
and those were all the Easter eggs
callbacks and reference
we found in the last of his part to any
we missed please let us know in the
comments below for more coverage on the
last of his part to stay tuned to games
pot
[Music]
[Music]